but that supposedly after the crown you
get recognized a lot more now when you
go to a party it yeah it was one kind of
horrifying moment where I was like we're
in the shop and on the way to a party I
was like I need to just pick up some
vodka so I picked up a big bottle of
vodka I was like what makes that other
stuff too I don't know couldn't decide
so I just had the bottle of vodka
and everyone else had drinks I was
walking down the street in Dalston I
like cracked it open I was like swinging
it down as I swinging a tower this girl
walks past me o'clock sighs I mean I
think maybe because like the drink and
the sort of expression on my face and
like the combination she sort of like
princesses like oh my god it's all true
because Ron wasn't then you were
recognized was at a honeymoon couple on
a Clara oh yeah there's a couple of they
were on a honeymoon and the plane hadn't
yet taken off and the the the woman
who'd just gotten married just became
violently and horribly ill on the plane
I mean it was not like a pretty little
like sick bag kind of thing it was just
like I'm going to paint with my organs
people were freaking out all over the
plane in the end there this said they
brought a stretcher down and they put
her on the stretcher and they're
wheeling her away and like the the her
new husband is just kind of cruising
along with the thing and he sees me and
he's like Deadpool like what does she
got he's like let's touch eyeballs by
the way your wife is like half dead man
so it was just a very surreal moment I'm
sure they're fine I'm sure they're on
their second anniversary now he's
kicking it somewhere
[Music]